[Musique]
eh bien il fait très beau aujourd'hui on
a une bonne idée d'aller sur la plage
[Musique]
et qui va se baigner c'est sa chance et
qui va crier c'est ton choix
[Applaudissements]
pour plages ne faut pas se laisser aller
n'est ce pas tant en voix
[Applaudissements]
ah non cette fois les autres chaînes
sont allés trop loin et watt wash
notation craint de chiens ce noir
derrière toi
ma
[Musique]
tiens pétroliers
et ben laden mais au fond qu'est ce
qu'ils font mais voilà même mais je rêve
mais c'est une marée noire en les
inconscients et tonton jo a créé deux
chiens qui vont baigner et lui le
commandant qui qu'est-ce qu'il va réagir
enfin attention cette colo plume de
tonton soit il ne peut plus nager
tiens bon trait de chiens vas-y ne lâche
pas
je
et tout ça cause un commandant qui est
complètement fou sous sa casquette
[Musique]
et moi c'est la scarlatine maintenant
c'est lamazou tine
[Musique]
quand même le commandant s'est aperçu de
sa bêtise qu'il est happé par des pompes
aspirantes watts watteau tu es un génie
[Musique]
mais les marins ont l'air malin tiens
s'ils n'avaient pas tous ali et bien il
ne serait pas là en train de nettoyer
[Musique]
merci à toi tout
et
du